the rumors about a firefly reboot will
just not go away
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
every few weeks another story comes out
that firefly is going to be remade by
disney
and to be honest i really hope all of
those stories
are false i kind of hope disney never
remake firefly for a couple of big
reasons
have a look at all of the proposed
projects for star wars in 2022. the book
of boba fett is just the beginning that
we're gonna get obi-wan kenobi series
and just god there's about six others
there are loads and loads of projects
disney are really good at squeezing
every last drop of blood out of every
stone they own
and they are desperate for more content
there is a lot of money being spent on
these streaming services netflix amazon
and mainly disney plus
to create as much content as possible
they are completely at war with each
other so
i actually genuinely believe that this
story that was started by giant freaking
robot which we know are a bunch of
click-baiting
balance
because it still gets talked about so
much on social media facebook groups and
so on and so on i think disney will take
that as a massive big tick that this is
an easy book
an easy project that will get interest
and at the end of the day that's all
they really care about they get lots of
interest on social media people will
watch the show
if it's good great if it isn't there but
it's an easy win for disney plus
but this made me think should they do
it and it came down to this i basically
have been trying to talk my son into
watching firefly he's a big nathan
phillian fan he loves the rookie he
loves castle he actually what recently
watched the entire series of castle all
i see here is back to back straight
through
and he thinks nathan fillion is
brilliant so i went look there's this
firefly series he's great in it it's a
show that he nathan fillion actually
talked about wanting to buy a few years
ago because he loves the show so much
give it a go and my son's like well tell
me about it what's it like and i went
okay
it's a sci-fi show so they're aboard a
spaceship he likes sci-fi he loves
sci-fi books and things so i thought
that was an easy one boom done
earth earth that was as we've burned all
through all the resources we've we've
poisoned the planet so we moved to
another solar system we've terraformed
all the other planets and so there's um
this this hierarchy there's like the
poor people in the outer planets in the
inner planet so the rich more powerful
people and he's like great okay and they
had a civil war brilliant okay he's
totally on board and it's all like a
western in space and that's when i lost
him
and this comes down to basically one of
the main reasons why firefly was kind of
unsuccessful in the first place
the premise
a big part of it and a big part of why
it actually worked and what made it so
brilliant is the western and space part
that was a big problem with the show
because even when i saw it and i am the
biggest brand coach in the world
um
even when i saw the initial adverts i
went that looks silly
that looks stupid i'm not watching it
and my son did amazing i saw his eyes
glazed over as soon as i tried to
explain that part to him as soon as i
was trying to explain some of the
episodes i lost him
i was trying to explain to him that this
is very much a character-driven show
though and that as soon as you start
watching it you will fall in love with
these characters you will fall in love
with mal you'll fall in love with wash
and zoe and river and simon a little bit
and you know and you will
genuinely care what happens to them
watch the show
and don't think about it too much
and to be afraid he's about halfway
through the series and i think he's
converted
but the problem with it is that the but
really this comes down to my problem
with explaining to him why he should
watch the show
and why
he
struggled with it is why a remake won't
work
it was very much nathan fillion and the
other characters that made this show and
listening to us if we have a new show
it's either going to be a hard reboot
where they basically forget the original
show ever happened or at very least
um it'll be aboard a new ship some
things they can reference the old series
but they won't really connect it or they
do sort of a softer reboot and they try
and bring some of the characters back
now couches like river and simon could
come back jane
has aged quite badly so i'm not 100
certain i want to see that but
hey it could happen
and wash is obviously dead and but zoe
could come back they've appeared in
comic books together and the comic books
again is another reason why i'm sure
certain disney will bring this back
because they've been very popular
so a couple of these characters could
return
but if i'm honest
without mal
and without nathan fillion it's not
going to work the other characters
cannot carry that show on their own in
my opinion
they might work
aside thing but let's be honest simon is
not going to be a main character in any
series he's not interested enough
um and the same goes for zoe really and
even for jane they cannot carry a show
on their own nathan fillion can
to be honest i think actually alan tudyk
could have done if they hadn't have
killed him off
either of those two characters or
hopefully those two characters together
if they'd have come back into a project
without the rest of the cast we'd have
watched it and we'd have loved it we
wouldn't have cared about the rest of
the cast
the rest of the cast come back without
nathan fillion or without alan tudik
it's not going to be the show no one's
going to really care
so in that case i don't think they would
do that they might bring one or two of
those characters back as a sort of
as a nod to the old series but that
would be about it i think it's more
likely and also because so much time has
gone by now since the series
i think they'll just do a hard reboot
now for me whether they do a hard be
reboot or not
you've got the basic premise of the
series and it's not a bad premise it's a
good first i like you know earth that
was burned out gone to an event but
moved on
you could bring that the wild west thing
i toned it down a little bit definitely
very least for the advertisement when
you're advertising the series don't
focus so much on the wild western space
[ __ ]
have it in the show because it's what
made firefly but maybe don't focus on it
too much because it's also what turned a
lot of people off
but then
move on with a new show
between
it's just it's just a completely new
show then really calling it firefly
basically just
you know it's gonna it's gonna okay it's
gonna get a lot of advertisement it's
gonna get a lot of people getting very
angry about it which kind of they
actually quite like because
that's and no advertisement is no free
advertisement is a bad thing
um you know
they'll love it when people get angry
people got really angry when they're
starting the next generation came out
and when battlestar galactica came out
um and all these other projects
even lost in space run that was revamped
people went crazy um not to the same
degree but they did um you know so these
things happen and i and i
i wouldn't get upset about it though
basically it's just a name it doesn't
take away anything from the original
series it's still going to be there for
us to love and rewatch
it's just a new tv show loosely based on
something we used to love with the same
title
i would love it if they very least got
nathan fillion to come back as an
executive producer and i actually think
that is potentially possible i know he's
very busy on the rookie at the moment
but that is a tv series for me that
isn't going to have like a seven eight
nine year series run it's quite a
limited
um premise to that series that the point
is that he's an older guy
as a new copper once he's had a been
experienced for a couple of years he's
not a rookie anymore really
does that show have the legs to keep
going
so if that was to end
a nathaphilian wanted to return in
firefly that could really work
or if he wanted to return as an
executive producer i think that's
something that could get fans on board
what do i think they're gonna do a
firefly
i think disney will make a series i
think it'll be called firefly i think
it'll have
very little
very loosely connected to the original
series
i don't think any of the production
people will be involved
and i i very much doubt any of the
actors will be involved
it'll just be a new show
with an old title
and that's what i think
so please leave a comment tell me what
do you think disney are going to do with
a firefighter franchise now that they
own it
and if it does return will it even be a
shadow of its former self
if you are new to the channel as well
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification hit the like button hit all
of those little buttons and share it
wherever the hell you like and
join us on facebook there's a link in
the description also we're on twitter
please go and tell me what you think on
there and go on facebook and share all
your memes and things is cool
thank you very much for watching stay
safe i'll see you next time